FOUR ON THE SHOT CLOCK.
FALLING AWAY.
TATUM -- SHORT.
SMART COMES UP WITH THE BALL,
BUT COULDN'T HOLD ON.
EVERYBODY DIVES ON THE FLOOR.
CURRY COMES UP WITH IT.
HORFORD HAS IT.
SMART WRESTLES IT AWAY -- AND A
FOUL ON GOLDEN STATE.
ALL-OUT EFFORT FROM BOTH TEAMS.
>> Mark: STEPH CURRY IS LAYING
DOWN -- NOT SURE IF HE GOT HURT
AS THEY WERE DIVING FOR LOOSE
BALLS.
>> Mike: YOU SEE CURRY WINCING
RIGHT NOW AND THAT FOUL IS ON
DRAYMOND GREEN.
HE HAS FOULED OUT, WITH 4:07
REMAINING.
MUCH TO THE DELIGHT OF THIS
CROWD.
GREEN'S GOT TO BE CAREFUL, HE'S
GIVING THE REFEREE AN EARFUL.
>> Jeff: THE WARRIORS NEED ALL
FIVE GUYS IN THERE.
THEY'RE SMALL, THEY'RE
UNATHLETIC --
>> Mark: I LOOKED LIKE STEPH
CURRY GOT HURT AS AL HORFORD
DOVE FOR THE LOOSE BALL, LANDED
ON HIS LEG.
>> Mike: WELL, CURRY IS LIMPING
RIGHT NOW.
HE'S UPSET.